foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the Colts the former League MVP led
the Colts to a win over the Jags they're
now three two and one
how the hell are you guys three two and
one man can you explain that to me
uh no you know it's it's it's really
been
uh an interesting first you know six
games here
um but we are where we are and we're
right in the mix and so six games into
it you know honestly
um you just you know obviously you'd
like to be 6-0 but we're not but but
we're we're where we need to be uh in
order to accomplish what we want to
accomplish but also when you go from you
know the Falcons in a system and you
were comfortable and then you go to a
new team like Russell Wilson with
Seattle now goes to Denver how big a
transition is that for you know even
guys who are Hall of Fame quarterbacks
yeah it's
I mean it's it's hard for it it's
probably a little harder than you think
it's going to be you know you think
you're just hey I'm gonna go there and
do exactly what I've done you know my
entire it's just different you know you
get in and the day-to-day operation of
the building the coaches you know I I
thought
um you know I thought having gone
through coaching Transitions and stuff
like that it would help and I think to a
certain extent you know it did during my
time in Atlanta
but it really feels a lot like being a
rookie again uh because not only are you
learning you know new offense you get
used to new coaches for the first time
in 14 years I'm learning a completely
new roster you know even in those
coaching transitions we had in Atlanta
you still had pieces that that you knew
and and that continuity helped uh go
through some of those things do you know
everybody's name on the roster
[Laughter]
don't put me on the spot thank God I
think on the right the roster I'm pretty
good what kills me you know or not kills
me but what's hard is
you know when you're in the same
building for 14 years and you walk
around you know everybody right and and
so you can say hello you can
I still struggle at certain times of
like oh hey yeah and it's hard because
they all know your name you know and you
don't want to be you don't want to be
okay so I I'm going to be somebody in
the office and you don't know my name
how would you handle it when I go hey
Matt hey great great win against the
Jaguars thanks man how you doing good
good do you know my name Matt
then if you put me on the spot that's
where I just go with no I don't I don't
I'm sorry you got roughed up those first
couple of games in more ways than one
but you know do you change anything when
you you're not playing like they think
you're supposed to be playing you're not
playing like you think you're supposed
to be playing so then what goes through
your mind
yeah I think you know all athletes
um you know it's it's part of
professional sports I mean if you hang
around long enough there's going to be
the ups there's going to be the downs
and um
you got to keep plugging away and you
got to keep believing that you know your
best is is coming you know the next time
you suit up I think you focus on
practice you focus on trying to you know
work on good habits uh in practice and
um you know that's that's what I've
always done even even from being a young
player when things aren't good you know
I think I think you get really simple in
those kind of situations you simplify
and you work on the fundamentals and you
go back to that uh and you hammer away
at those and and
um you know that's what I've what I've
tried to do the last handful of weeks
okay when you go home does Mom say to
everybody don't bring up
the game if you have a bad game how does
it work when you walk into the house
my kids got no filter
um and so you know they'll humble you
pretty pretty good and you know like
they're starting to get it so I've got
twin boys and and they're four and a
half and they're they they kind of you
know understand what's going on and they
understand wins and losses
um and they're like Dad you didn't throw
any touchdowns what's up with that and
I'm sorry hey man it's harder than it
looks you know uh but it's it's funny
it's funny to see it and uh you know
luckily you know this past week they
were fired up and excited we won we're
talking Matt Ryan or the Colts do you
know who has gotten the benefit of more
roughing the passer calls in the last
five years
I'm assuming it's me yes it is
congratulations yeah yeah yeah I'm not
sure that's a good thing though because
it means you are getting hit
you know okay I think that might be like
a quantity thing yeah it is but but I'm
wondering like Brady's been given uh
rough in the pastor 15 times I think
you've been given 29 times
do you damn why are you bringing this up
well I'm just curious I should have just
let this sweep right under the rug but
I'm not alert are you selling it better
than Brady is is because you've got to
be faster than Brady so it's not like
he's you're not slower than Brady right
there's no chance okay
um I think he's like one of three or
four people I can probably beat in a
foot race in the sleep but I'm I feel
pretty confident in that one but do you
sell me back I didn't I didn't I say I
have one this past weekend
there was nothing I needed to sell I
mean he was pushing my neck and my neck
feels it today you know uh because of it
so
um but yes I mean it's not like a flop
in soccer but anytime I mean honestly
anytime anytime you're hit around the
head I mean I do I turn around and look
and let them know
um but it's up to them to call it but
also you have to now factor in if I give
the impression that I'm a little more
banged up than what I am then you get
pulled out with this sort of uh over
protection new protocol here with
quarterbacks yeah yeah it's you know I
think that
I think the rule changes have been good
you know to be honest with you like
um I I get you know trying to protect
it's it's become more of more of a of a
Passing League you know we all know that
and and I I get trying to protect you
know the guys who are out there that
make it entertaining exciting for fans
um but it's hard you know like I think
the ones below the knee and I think the
ones kind of above the shoulders I think
they're pretty easy to to officiate you
know I I do think it's the ones that are
going to the ground
um and you know Landing with full force
or whipping though those get subjective
and and those are tough and um you know
I'm not gonna lie I always like it when
they call them and it's you know and
it's in our favor but
you look at the defensive guys and you
go through these meetings and you you
sit there and you listen to coaches
trying to explain
how to play and and it's
I don't know I don't know what to say
you know so I think uh that part of it
is is really tough
okay what would you suggest if the
competition committee came to you and
said
you know defensive linemen or you know
anybody who's going to hit the
quarterback how can we make it so it
doesn't feel like
you guys are over protected
I I don't think it's easy you know I I
really don't because
you know I
like I don't think you want to go back I
I really don't I don't think you want to
take steps back to where
um
you know where you're getting that full
force landing on because
you know the the amount of I've always
said you know to people like it's not
the impact the guy hit you with that
usually Hurts the Most it's the ground
you know like the ground continues to
wear you out so I think
I think it's good what they're trying to
do maybe you make some of them
reviewable kind of like they do in
college football with the targeting
um you know where where they have the
ability to review whether or not it was
um so it's not you know quite as
you know difficult to make that decision
uh in terms of real time so you would
would you change the playing surface you
think that that's a bigger culprit than
you know how they're actually calling
the hits on a quarterback you mean the
playing surface in terms of like field
turf or yeah like grass would that
change things would that feel different
than you know what you're falling on now
um I always think grass feels better
like it if I've played a game my hips my
knees you know all those kind of things
feel better after having played on grass
but to be honest with you when you're
getting when you're getting taken down
you know into it
you don't know the difference of whether
or not you're on turf or you're on grass
it just hurts so 320 on turf or 320 on
grass It's Gonna Hurt yeah it's it's not
you know it's not you know and I've
played long enough to where you know
I've seen the difference of you know
full force being able to take you to you
know to to the ground and the difference
um in those things and and uh I think
it's a good thing how many times you
think you've been sacked in your career
laughs
oh I don't know
um
just give me again you know 15 years
roughly 15 years and
I don't know three four hundred Paulie
you got the exact number I got 471 for
Matt Ryan
471. yeah do you remember one of the 471
more than any of the other
um there was one in the Super Bowl oh
yeah
ouch
thanks Dan sorry I appreciate it
thank you
oh sorry about that no it's honestly one
I remember the most
um I was a and I it probably doesn't
even count as a sack I was a rookie we
were playing in Carolina uh oddly enough
John Fox who's on our staff now was the
head coach in Carolina and I was playing
up there I think it was maybe week three
or four and like first drive of the game
I got smoked by Julius Peppers right
across the chin through a pick six it
came back and it was one of those
roughing the passer uh calls that that
you talked about earlier it ended up
coming back but I remember being hit
like that and being like oh man this is
this is gonna be a different day buckle
up
so I should have how many regular season
sacks that's what I should have that's
that should have or the most painful no
no physically the most yeah see I got to
work with my staff there Matt you know
we were workshopping this and I brought
up the Super Bowl I'm with you man
you're always good as the guys around
you yeah
and it feels like we're three two and
one I think in here Matt hell it's over
500 we'll take it yes does the Super
Bowl come up in Indianapolis very often
as you know much as it might have in
Atlanta or when people would interview
you
no you know I I don't think it's it's
it's
I guess for lack of a better term my
baggage not their baggage you know
there's there's
um lots of lots of things that have gone
on here that that I wasn't aware of
before too that that you're kind of you
know coming into
um but it only comes out when you know
people are asking me to tell them how
many sacks I have in my career and
trying to you know go through that
why does Matt come on with us every year
if we treat him this way
oh Dan you're the best uh you got the
Titans you guys play the Titans is it
every other week or every three weeks it
feels like you play the Titans yeah it
seems like it seems like it's that yeah
something something like that uh since
I've been here it's uh it's quick I mean
what's Wild is you know it's five of
five of our uh first seven are in
division which I don't think at any
point in my career I've ever you know
I've ever had that many games uh front
loaded you know I've I've had a lot of
them where you have that in the back end
where you know you have a chance to you
know either pick up ground or close
ground whatever you need to do uh but
it's it's definitely different this year
playing Five the first seven in division
great to talk to you as always and uh
hopefully you don't add to this sack
total or the roughing the passer
everything's going to be good no worries
against the Titans you don't have to
worry about that defense right
not at all not at all thanks Dan I
appreciate it man thank you man that's
uh Matt Ryan yeah Paulie said you know
he's come on with us ever I think we
talked to him when he was still at
Boston College